des coquillages évidemment aux mains
qu'est ce que c'est ça mais ça m'a l'air
très prometteur
à
c'est l'heure du festin oui j'arrive
tout est rose hill non mais matt moi un
peu ces merveilles arrête
j'en ai déjà l'eau muzeau non mais t'as
vu tous ces autres ait rien de meilleur
qu'un scarabée sous la dent et dans la
venise ses clients je peux pas résister
salle voleurs carmelo ce n'était pas
très sympa non c'est l'heure du festin
acte qui vient pas il copains sont déjà
là ouais ouais
j'arrive vraiment obligé de faire ça
tous les jours est ce que tu nous
apportes aujourd'hui et ben je suis pas
sûr de savoir ce que c'est non pas que
je voulais dire pour le système qu'est
ce que tu crois il va encore pointé avec
rien entre les pattes plus long terme et
les amis les amis je crois que cette
fois j'ai vraiment fait une découverte
incroyable
visez un peu quoi papy tu y vois
vraiment pur et par ici locher que
jamais d'un coup tu rêves pas byzance
c'est pas de la nourriture
c'est la preuve qu'il existe d'entre
terre en dehors de notre île et voilà
c'est reparti quoi je sais que c'est
vrai est ce que pour une fois on pourra
déjeuner tranquille d'accord je voulais
ce déjeuner dès que l'homme mort à 10-12
cette chance peut bien sortir le sort de
l'eau je vote pour carmelo ouais je vote
moi aussi pour cars mais je vois que moi
je sais pour carmelo opitz il s'agit pas
d'une élection ce bidule machin choix
était quoi tu veux savoir ce que j'en
pense
je pense que cette chose sera tout ce
que tu veux qu'elle soit